peu
[Musique]
on
c'est votre dernier pensionnaire
monseigneur au l'avant-dernier ça c'est
pis pour encore nous a amenés un jour et
que nous avons verger et qui et de quoi
le plus en ce gentil sujet du biseau oui
at-il je pense du gabon gabon ali bongo
cage atilano alors avec de plus que
nantes
on fait souvent des cadeaux a si souvent
quelques-uns sont embarrassants et
au lieu de se mêler fanta cadeau de
rester bao dai à peu près 15 ans quand
le zoo a débuté cette pathologie
considérer votre propriété personnelle
oui je vous avais donc créé comme liège
par par conviction par par intérêt we
will par obi bondi parce que j'adore les
animaux depuis titans et au cours d'une
croisière que j'avais fait en afrique
avec mon bateau je vais ramener de
conakry trente deux animaux avaient
encore vivant il faut prix les
crocodiles les autriche des chimpanzés
et ça a été le départ du zoo
et là il fallait bien les mettre quelque
part en arrivant est allé j'ai mis ça
dans une partie du jardin après sa
prévision en cours d année d une
extension et il a fallu agrandir
aménagés mais on ne peut pas tout avoir
dans un parc zoologique à risque il ya
des animaux pour lesquelles vous
éprouvez plus d'intérêt que d'autres
puis certainement moi je crois d'abord
les autres pays il intéresse beaucoup
et puis alors les certains fauves la
plupart des grands fauves mais cet autre
chose cazaux moi j'ai voulu faire un
centre d'acclimatation jeu
logique pour voir si dans l'eau climat
ici les reproductions ce fonds et les
animaux africains et les animaux même
amérique du sud amérique du nouveau
monde des animaux sur police très bien
quand au fond riche tout simplement vous
avez eu beaucoup de réactions coup de
réussite du côté entreprises que vous
avez c'est beaucoup plus long d'abord il
a gagné l'âge de collection au bout de
neuf ans ou dix ans et elle est tout ce
que j'ai sont des sujets très jeune et
sont très difficiles à elle-même ils
sont très difficiles sont très délicats
mais je compte dans ce climat ils se
plaisent pas vraiment parfaitement
vous avez d'ailleurs effectivement une
très belle collection anthropoïdes et en
particulier quelque chose qui est assez
rare en france vous avez un
un gorille qui n'est pas adulte encore
puisqu'il a disons pourquoi mais qui a
presque la taille d'un adulte en règle
[Musique]
covidien vérifier mais le pape a promené
un peu dure à aller qu'il ya la montée
courte
g
[Musique]
de cela
trop
pour atta
[Musique]
les grandes entreprises sont déjà rares
en parc zoologique parce qu'ils sont
difficiles à élever mais je crois que
laurent autant est encore plus rare et
le plus rare des entreprises et surtout
qu'il très rare à trouver sauf que
malheureusement on en trouve un peu trop
en contrebande et dans vous gênez
rendant une taxe santé terrible
puisqu'ils sont tous rachitique ou
maladif et alors il ya un énorme déchet
et dans les eaux quelquefois aussi après
une très grande réussite
et c'est pour ça que vous voyez
généralement des sujets petit son salon
des sujets qui sont là depuis très
longtemps et qui ont été élevés
presqu'au artificiellement
c'est difficile à élever très c'était
difficile parce que c'est quand même
temps délicat mais je crois que là
encore je crois que ces animaux là qui
sont d'ordre et parce que toute l'année
à cause du climat trouve ici est une
adaptation difficile du soleil de monte
carlo
parce que pour sujet de ceux de son âge
il est déjà en pleine forme puisqu'il
pèse 75 kg conséquent à lancer
différents seuils tous les animaux
sauvages dit sauvage généralement quand
ils atteignent la taille adulte ou alors
qu'ils ont eu un contact avec des
semelles ou alors sans très difficile
parce qu'ils sont jaloux en moi je
difficile et ont pu les sortir de nous
considérer que vous devez le laisser
enfermer
dans sa cage et à partir de quel âge
complètement oui complètement enfants à
partir de 10 ans lui déjà va avec la
femelle ils sont ensemble une partie de
la matinée mais ils se sont donnés pas
que ce sont à l'orage encore des bb bb b
presque et alors qu'est ce que tu as tu
es fâché ce matin bonjour mon fils un
jour bonjour falloir comme turbo voir
contient bourru youtube ou un monfils
tort de dire je cherche et bien regardez
qu'est ce qui à l'arrière mérite bien
regarde pas le monde à l'envers et jojo
tiens donc que c'est bon ça vous que ce
pensent ou que ce boss ou que c'est bon
qu'est ce qui te arrière droit regarde
regarde bonjour bonjour et à bord est à
revoir c'est en l'an 2 comme telle à ce
que je sache que tu veux te rappelles
toi
tiens
jour leur art à moustache fait d'avoir
su moustache le voir ou à la moustache
est au ballon pour ça que tu as toujours
des allemands et alors c'est bon là là
là tu te voir quand tu bouffes mince
avance avec ton père lun 12 semaines
voilà
hier qu'il ya eu divers
skis
je viens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sarah
à
cours
bush
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
par contre alors chez les faux vous avez
de très nombreuses naissances
puis chaque année ça on peut dire que
surtout chez les tigres chez les lions
n'ont pas ce que vous savez comme moi
qui ai un problème pour ils ont écoulé
les jeunes lions personne n'en veut
alors c'est un peu difficile mais cela
lyon l'enfant fait pas du tout de leur
production et puis là pour pour amuser
pourra tester public vous avez créé à
l'intérieur du parc zoologique une école
de dressage
oui c'est une école d'amateurs dix ans
mais c'est toujours dans la même idée je
vous disais tout à l'heure que au fond
l'intérêt de ceux qui partent c'est que
les gens soit en contact avec les bad
beats sauvage on se demande du reste
faut qu'on les appelle sauvage
esi pour chaque les cages de faux sang
des cages un peu curieuse vous les gens
le public sont le nez sur le lab est
s'il ya donc un véritable contact les
écoles ou ce qu'on appelle l' école de
dressage est aussi à l'école de contacts
au fond entre l'individu et entre
l'humain et les jeunes faut bien entendu
puisqu'on ne peut pas risquer de les
mettre en contact avec des fauves
adultes une audience est une école de
dressage pour les fondre ou une école de
dressage pour les 80 heures c'est y
aller comme ce robot je crois pas que ce
soit les futurs docteurs nous n'avons je
crois qu'un seul candidat qui aimeraient
à la rigueur faire une carrière
mais la plupart sont les actes il où il
ya les directeurs commerciaux qui
viennent pendant quelques temps et au
fond c'est une école de dressage à 207
une école de dressage pour humains et
pour fo il se dresse mutuellement
voilà alors ils apprennent à ne pas
avoir peur l'un de l'autre il ya un
contact très bon moniteur qui fait une
spécialité de présenter
je trouve qu aussi s'il sort de
l'afrique bon docteur en douceur ce sera
une très bonne chose non hassi ba da
place bada place va t'asseoir a6 a6k
aussi terribles a bow wow higway en
place tôt mais t'as doublé t'es bon jeu
d'abou tabou voilà c'est très bien non
non
restez calme reste précaire
voilà c'est très bien comme ça et dans
ma belle voix voilà c'est bien on va
aller reste tranquille rachida
marter ap est en place
arte
ap est en place
luna parker
nous apparaît non ici à vous ap ap le
nom londres ap ap ap hm braves
ap ap le mans ap ap le mans
nous non ap ap ap
bravo en place assise ainsi cheveux et
de vous
encore une fois debout
voilà c'est bien très bien brave sun ra
bravo tu occupes a alors assis assis
blême ah si je tape non assise bravo mon
fils assis à si long long long long long
long jeunes loups n'ont cogné à loulo
loulo loulo long
bravo à six toiles ici toi lucy bradshaw
est debout
non non l'ami l'a mis là me tape non
lamy l'ami y ait pas d'effet sur la mine
lac l'ami lamic l'ami voile c'est bien
aux aux programmes et aux grammy
d'amiraux au aura mis aux grammy au
oprah
bright eyes marchent marchent coucher
coucher donc non qu'est ce que vous
faites pour lui de bien s'ils restent
couchés la l'acquiert couché non
l'acquis la quille
la quille l'acquis l'acquis
couché
enfin pour acheter une raisonnable un
putois la barre est alors couché coucher
ici c'est ça
hier
plus aligné avance légèrement avant soit
un peu là qui est mis en avant
là qui est mis en avant couché voilà
dans ça c'est mieux
vous êtes mieux aligner évidement toi
là-bas te font s'ils avaient spéciale va
chez nous
[Musique]
à
non
m
une
ce jour
du
[Musique]
oh
où
en
[Musique]
penses tu
je peux
il
oh
[Musique]
on
oh
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
c'est gentil comme est malheureusement
c'est aussi en voie de disparition
puisque les premiers que j'ai eu 2 qui
venait du sétois étaient déjà par le
mazout et malades elles sont mortes du
reste peu de temps après l'arrivée
alors il est obligé de faire du service
parce que sinon lui le mal est
extrêmement violent avec 6 croisé et on
n'arrive pas à les nourrir les violents
et bruyant violent et bruyant
[Applaudissements]
la retravailler encore pascal ils sont
là depuis assez peu de temps devant lui
commence à manger en hauteur combien de
kilos de poissons par jour par tête 6 kg
acculé c'est à peu près l'équivalent des
dauphins grèce qui mangent à peu près la
même quantité
[Applaudissements]
vous à manger deux fois par jour ils
reçoivent généralement à manger par le
gardien deux fois par jour pendant 10
ans daisy tu fais les visiteurs peuvent
eux aussi leur donner à manger deux fois
sont à la fois rko
[Applaudissements]
m
s'évaluer valeur de soi ça c'est du mak
rouler les hausses étaient des sardines
sont pas tenus à son endroit
alors deux mais surtout des macros vous
m'avez dit monseigneur ce parc
zoologique c'est un hobby pour moi mais
est ce que ça ne représente pas
également autre chose pour vous je crois
certainement comme tous les habits c'est
une évasion ça me permet de retrouver
ici des les animaux j'aime qui sont au
fond des amis alors je crois que pour
les ans les jeunes gens les enfants
c'est quand même une bonne indication de
leur montrer des espèces qui sont toutes
en voie de disparition finalement ou
pour les causes de pollution ou parce
que l'homme ne sait pas se restreindre
dans ces plaisirs et continue des
safaris idiot
soit on gagne soit en afrique espèces
qu'on peut
espérée par conséquent sauvé grâce à des
jardins géologiques comme je crois
certainement des gens la logique un
grand rôle à jouer en montrant les
espèces animales et je compte le jardin
zoologique surtout ne doit pas devenir
un musée où on montrera les espèces
éteintes
[Musique]
oh
et
maintenant
[Musique]